liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger heute
wende ich mich zum letzten mal auf
diesem wege an sie das erste mal liegt
nun schon mehr als 15 jahre zurück
damals war das eine ziemliche
besonderheit dass ich eine
regierungschefin im netz so direkt an
die öffentlichkeit wendet und ich konnte
es kaum glauben als jetzt jemand
ausgerechnet hat das seitdem mehr als
600 folgen dazu gekommen sind und
deswegen erlauben sie mir heute ein
letztes mal zu sagen was mir in diesen
tagen das allerwichtigste ist
wir sind mitten in dieser vierten
pandemiewelle in einer sehr ernsten lage
in manchen teilen unseres landes kann
man sie nur dramatisch nennen das ist so
bitter weil es vermeidbar wäre mit den
wirksamen und sicheren impfstoffen haben
wir den schlüssel dazu in der hand ich
bitte sie daher noch einmal eindringlich
nehmen sie das tückische virus erst
gerade die neue variante omikron scheint
noch ansteckender zu sein als die
bisherigen lassen sie sich impfen egal
ob erst im funk oder booster jede
impfung hilft dem geimpften gibt die
sicherheit mindestens einen
ausgezeichneten schutz vor einem
schweren krankheitsverlauf und eine
möglichst hohe importe hilft uns allen
als land diese pandemie hinter uns zu
lassen